miios I was gonna go within everyone
it's about me you brought me back you're
getting lots of negativity about good
morning Millennials but I don't want to
face me no negativity definitely fuels
you for sure let me say it more and
harder and like it was a thicker accent
good morning everyone welcome back to
the morning toast it's a bright and
sunny Wednesday here in New York New
Jack city it's not that bright and it's
not that sunny but it's been good enough
it's better than Monday and it's better
than Monday do you see those videos of
the subways flooding discuss that is
crazy and what was crazier is that by
the afternoon it was bright and sunny
really April showers do you bring many
flowers this was my thought like the
rising water in the subways coming down
from the stairs like the filth like I
couldn't what's worse than filth is wet
filth yeah I completely it was so
disgusting that video made me want to
move like ASAP yeah but like that's
mother nature like that's no one's fault
the subway is not mother nature no no no
but it going into the subway like that's
no one's fault totally happen like how
has that never been a problem before
like they're literally wide open holes
in the street and maybe they have been
just like bar still didn't post a video
about it yeah no I only saw it's almost
exactly Jackie and I are here to deliver
the Fast Five story is that you need to
know before you wake up and smell your
own Oh smell your own morning toast
smell very crispy someone sent me a
photo of their avocado toast this
morning and it was a supreme we have a
jam-packed day five really well-rounded
important stories and then we're
bringing back a favorite segment of
everyone's called dear toasters you
asked we delivered you asked we're going
to answer and we still don't know what
they are we haven't read them getting
our reactions are unsolicited solicited
advice live and I'm so excited to be
back sharing our wealth of knowledge
yeah with the masses it's been a while
since I changed someone's life and I'm
really feeling like today I looked at
words yeah speaking of life-changing
content we announced yesterday on our
morning toasters Facebook page that we
have started a patreon account and
before we move forward I just want to
clarify what it is because a lot of
people were confused about like this
show it's free always be below Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
always free we would never take that
away always premium that you fast I
thing they didn't need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast that will never
change it will always be the past five
tangents and break oh i'm before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast but a lot of the
complaints we get is that they wish the
show was a little bit longer which we
cannot do obviously but we can't get
extra premium content to those who want
it so we started a patreon account you
do not have to sign up you could still
be a very informed toaster if you don't
and just be toasting and not a premium
toaster but if you got the $7.99 a month
and want to hear more about what
happened to me in middle school which by
the way is very interesting I would
think the dichotomy here is that like
okay so I know what the question is and
we're gonna talk about it in the patreon
panel because like I don't want this
show to devolve into like a show that
talks about the right guys great I agree
it's it's patriotic too dark it's paint
it's it's toast after dark it's like the
HBO of the toast like this is like
primetime cable you know family-friendly
show yes and that's like a sort of
nudity a little bit more today yeah and
there will be us like we can't talk
about ourselves all the time you got a
show so we'll be able to do that on the
patreon account if you're interested in
the premium toast experience go for it
just remember that premium content does
not grow on trees therefore it is $7.99
a month premium content doesn't grow on
trees anymore actually it still does Oh
Rose um fern it grows on plastic ferns
anyways I'm so excited to jump right
into the show mm-hmm are you ready for
your first story I mean I haven't really
delved into the stories another first
one I'm kind of enjoying you like
reacting on any news I'm such a reactor
you know such an honor yeah yeah on air
former first lady barbara Bush has died
at the age of 92
that is so old like I feel like she
lived a good life buddy that's a
wonderful life she's some lovely one Air
Force one yeah Andy Cohen instagrammed
about her death like that's all you can
really ask for in a life and also to
like find your soul mate at the age of
16 and have a 76 year marriage that is
just full of love you can also be
married to the president and and have a
son who's the president yeah also he's
supposed to be so proud but like to have
a marriage for so long but like there
was some stuff like about HW but like
whatever yeah we want a in this eulogy
with that lets me know how a husband
who's the president the son who's the
president and the
son who's the governor red and a
granddaughter whose on Access Hollywood
I had you nephew who also were president
no um who was in separate wives Billy
Bush I'm sure that's what she disgraced
grandnephew whatever he is a former
Today Show disgraced host i disgraced
former Today Show will pick just that
one pointed Today Show host we should
make a chart with all the people Barbara
Bush is really the true and like why she
would be so proud of each and every one
of them except for Billy but I think
she's really she's definitely proud of
Jenna and the other one yeah Jenna Hagar
and Barbara she's that's Barbara Laura
no Laura is George's wife by the way
George George's daughters like were lit
like I feel like if I was like the
daughter of a president like a nineteen
year in your teen years I would want to
be a girl I would want to have a sister
I'd want to be like beautiful and like
like I feel like Malia and Sasha Obama
like we're too young
okay we're new but they also got the
perks they got the Jonas Brothers to
come to the White House when they were
like in Jonas Brothers age like they did
it right to for their age go further
ages yeah if I could choose I would want
to start like a two-term presidency when
I'm like 15 so then I gets like coming
to my own when I'm like 17 or 18 I can
like go to Coachella like things like
that I think Italy it was Sasha
especially was so young when he first
became president also like that age of
15 or some of like the most difficult
like seventeen year growing up in the
spotlight and you're like having acne
and like gaining weight and getting
seventeen seventeen seventeen and
debates eight years I'm 25 when and then
I'm like by the time I'm 25 and ready
like settle down I'm over the spot well
no I think I would want to start at 21
so like any drinking that idea was
telling oh my god their husbands
daughters oh right
my date with the president's daughter
what a great movie and you know what I
love it I'm sorry about the president's
daughter by the way I totally go to
school at home squad I'm he's like a
fancy signing up for your hair like I
haven't heard any complaints yet but I
just want to preempt it because you I
want the best audio for our viewers
thank you um the Obama girls went to
school in DC I had the bush girls I do
not know and
and the Trump children are grown um
achieve a bobby pin in your shirt right
now no I guess you do look right there
really do you feel it yeah it fell out
of my hair cuz it's like too baggy oh
yeah I was like is that what a great
opportunity to change your look to
change it I'm gonna go with a side braid
today but that yeah I was gonna say how
do you get it my patriotic Oni my
deepest condolences to the bush yeah but
it still needs to see how like how much
everyone loved her because we really
didn't agree with her George Bush Senior
as a president so I don't know my always
got to see him wheeled onto the
Superbowl field right which was so cute
and then like nobody picked him up so I
don't know much about Barbara Bush but
it seems like she was a wonderful lady
and a great first lady I just like she's
someone that everyone can kind of rally
right regardless of political
affiliation I just love like the
converging what's the walking across the
aisle is that the yes it's a reaching a
creature like that
that picture of George Bush the son and
Michelle Obama like embracing one
another I forget where like it's so
sweet and it's like so nice like if we
could all just get along
no there was that picture should be our
national symbol there was a time in the
world when like people didn't talk about
politics all the time in like you could
just agree like yeah agree to disagree
yeah and anyways so our thoughts and
prayers go out to the Bush family but
they're such a great family I hope yours
isn't lonely like HW he's like so like
you looking yeah but knowing him he
probably decide I'm yeah he has so many
children and like George's jr. is always
like painting and stuff have you seen
his painting have you seen his Instagram
yeah
it's so sad no it's me it's me it's me
it's me okay okay
speaking of like wonderful people that I
only want the best for Kelly Clarkson is
to host the 2018 Billboard Music Awards
finally I'm obsessed with this story
respect being given where respect is due
yeah I wonder what she's gonna be like
as a host I know I feel like people who
end up hating her
I always end up hating a host like
Vanessa it made me like her no it made
me hate her no she just wasn't afraid to
sway sway sway is a host you know I know
but like someone my when Miley hosted
like Katy Perry hosted the VMAs like
every time someone host it makes me hate
them so I just really hope this doesn't
happen for Kelly Clarkson
they never know like where to draw the
line in terms of energy well she said
this might help you to prepare for
hosting the Billboard Music Awards I
already have 20 costume changes planned
I'll be flying in like my girl pink and
calling Amy Schumer and Sarah Silverman
for jokes Sarah Silverman will Amy
Schumer balances it out like the only
reason anyone should call Sarah
Silverman it's for them to tell her to
stop working and go back to the hole she
crawled out of
I [ __ ] hate Sarah Silverman okay but
maybe she'll listen more to Amy Schumer
zolomon because like I feel like she is
comes from like a long line of like
Jewish comedians who are like really
respected and like well-regarded and
like I can't tell you one thing I've
ever seen her in that I liked except for
school of rock where she played the
character that like everyone was
supposed to hate me blues wife so like I
don't know I just really hate her and
she's like so well-respected in the
comedy world like - and rubriz respects
her and like she's the worst I know I
don't know you just can't love everyone
you know certainly not me we got almost
just put my water out of my brand new
graduate morning Beth mug that's two
times today morning toast mug
it would have been fact cuz you would
have just watered our ferns yes they
really do look a little dry I just I'm
so I'm so nervous Olivia I took I will
never hate her but you really do see a
lot about someone when they host like
member 1 GG hosting Oh God not that I
watch you know me neither but like this
is the thing like oh my god I had such a
good point to make and I take her
hearted right out of my mind take your
time that was it was along the lines of
like he's gone oh my thought was along
the lines of like whoever oh yes okay
my thought was like Kelly Clarkson has
like this wholehearted amazing just good
person like she definitely doesn't do
drugs she's like really family-oriented
she was down in the south like she's the
antithesis of like Hollywood and like
drugs and like cool so I feel like all
the cool people at like the Billboard
Music Awards I cos are gonna hate her I
feel like she doesn't get the respect
she deserves like she hasn't performed
at a big Hollywood function recently
where she can showcase her voice and
show people that she's so much more than
just the first winner or get an idol
she's so much more oh speaking of like
she needs to do that rendition of piece
by piece yes and start the board Music
Awards and then she'll at the respect
that she deserves peaking of Justin and
Kelly I watched the last og last night
which the first two episodes I watched
it's okay like I just love seeing Tracy
Morgan on TV and I think he's hilarious
like whatever he does like the show
itself it's like not that funny is it
weird that Tiffany Haddish is like such
a that's the problem and she's like the
worst they showed a clip when she was on
Fallon or Kimmel will never be able to
distinguish between them they showed a
clip of the last og with Tiffany Haddish
and it was like it felt like an episode
of like Law & Order like it was so
serious no she's like this serious
philanthropist who like lives in the
town and likes a mom who's like yeah
she's the one she's ned schneebly wife
she starts up minute exactly brings me
back to my point but my point Oh
something really funny that they did was
like the first episode they do a
flashback to when he got arrested and it
was the night of the season finale of
American Idol season 1 and it was just
like so funny they kept everyone in the
neighborhood was like you got Justin I
got gely it was funny that's what the
show the show itself honestly I don't
recommend really I know I just
I absolutely loved Tracy Morgan I want
to support him like I just can't believe
he's alive it's [ __ ] crazy and I just
continue to watch but I don't think I
would recommend to a friend maybe if you
don't love Tracy Morgan don't watching
you know what I'm ready for it to
rewatch 30 rock because it's been so
long that I've actually forgotten all
the storylines yeah so it'll feel fresh
to me meme enry watched it like a like a
year and a half ago but it's still I
need brain camp so I don't even remember
what happened yeah I watched it in
college but I've watched so many shows
since I watched 30 rock that my brain is
like my storage is full
totally and it's buy more storage are we
good on are we good on Kelly Clarkson
yeah I'm gonna hope she does a good job
and I was just like embarrass yourself
by being like weird in a weenie like
everyone else does I'm trying so hard
she should call you for sure a Billy
Gill [ __ ] Kelly just be cool yeah
actually she's really called countess
LaLanne yeah they really should have a
[ __ ] countess host an award show if
they want some real one day yeah she is
in music you know he's an amazing host
and
he's like getting his due but like I
could I could go for him hosting let me
think the bill more music words if
someone who's actually a host Andy Cohen
know who's like up-and-coming sort of
but is is here let me think let me think
you definitely know who he is
okay can move one more clue um okay I
could give you two different clues one
he does a lot of work with MTV right now
- yeah I completely agree just I don't
know his name give me one more second
Chad Charlamagne no oh but I love
Charlie
Charlamagne deserves all the business in
the world I [ __ ] know Charlie too but
no and then also I don't know why I
called him Chad his handle see the guy
okay that's just one more one more other
dates a girl revolve love the parents
Jay I think Charlamagne tha God would be
better but I love news ever get rid of
him or did he leave I don't know
confusing and then he took over for are
you the one but why didn't right
why did my bed yeah get the boot I don't
know maybe there's in the world because
it was a mouthful the hosting world is
just as we know it's very competitive
by your own ferns okay
next story man arrested outside Taylor
Swift's home he had a knife and a rope
safely knife rope and drugs and bullets
okay a Colorado man who was wearing a
mask and had a knife in his heart was
was it a Colorado man or a man because
that makes a big difference in the story
it was a man [ __ ] that is dangerous had
a knife in his car when he was arrested
outside a Beverly Hills home owned by
Taylor Swift was released from custody
at custody on Tuesday while police
continue their investigation
Julius Sandrock 38 was arrested Saturday
on suspicion of stalking after officers
went to the home Swift who lives in New
York wasn't at the home police said this
is a confusing police report sanrak was
freed from jail on Tuesday morning braai
according to an LA County because we
don't really do these things website but
he had intent yeah but you can't prove
intent it wasn't immediately clear
whether Sandberg had a lawyer
meanwhile police obtained the temporary
restraining order preventing sanrak firm
precess from possessing guns I don't
really understand restraining orders
like oh this I'm obsessed with Taylor's
what this piece of paper is going to
stop me like no one like it's just yeah
it wouldn't stop him from like doing
harm really but like I don't know I
think you I feel like I'm blinking a lot
too my eyelids feel tired already
really oh speaking of tired I don't have
to tell you how it better be good it's
crazy no I swear no I went to bed at
very early Ben went to Detroit at like
5:00 a.m. this morning so like we don't
read super early I was asleep by 11:00
and at 2:30
I hear tick tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick tick and I knew exactly
what the sound was but I figured that it
was so early I figured Ben was getting
up for the airport already he was making
eggs or something cuz he's on keto when
he's been making so many eggs it's so
annoying so he was the stove it was the
gas it was like you know before you turn
on the stove it's like you know I'm
talking about are you doubting your head
and I'm not in because I'm worried about
where the story's going so then I wake
up because this ticking doesn't stop and
Ben's not next to me and I'm like I'm
motorized screaming I'm like daddy
he said yeah the gas was literally like
non-stop coming we couldn't get it off I
was watching youtube videos in the
middle of the night trying to turn this
dip and then I realized they're like
unplug it I'm like where does the stove
plug into I didn't even know remove it
from the wall no no no a lot like pull
it out no no it was like it was under I
looked in a cabinet underneath and I got
to pull it out but like it was so scary
because when I got on my room it smelled
like gas and I'm neither if we just
close the door when we were sleeping we
wouldn't have heard it like we probably
would have died crazy that's crazy
that's so scary but that's like not the
first time that happened to you know so
a toaster oven simply got inside the
toaster oven
yeah and left it on the whole night okay
he needs to stop attempting to cook
thank you the lesson here but it's not
crazy that is I was still worried about
the ill and oh and then I couldn't go
back to bed and I think you can't just
run out of your apartment cuz it's a
building full of others right and like
once like you feel like you're gonna die
and then everything's fine like how are
you just expected to like slow your
heart rate down and go back to bed
yeah I could everything's fine maybe
I'll be you so where have you been up
since no I was up for an hour it was so
annoying that's so sad and Theo was fine
Theo didn't know what was in the crate
he's teaching the crate he's been
looking so good on insert noise they can
find tonight that's most Acacio supper
that's okay anyways [ __ ] love me
girls to see me girls on Broadway I
think we should see it just for like
research purposes yeah I don't really
want to support it though because it's a
bad idea but you never know you never
know what if it's good it's just like
Legally Blonde I'm Martin Oi I could
never remember if I've actually seen it
even it was bad but there was just one
good time did I see it and we saw the
chaos we saw in camp oh my god oh my god
you guys that was yeah and that girl who
played L she's like a country singer
Laura Bell Bundy she's great oh but I
thought you never saw I think it's a
good idea does anyone see that
what about frozen on Broadway have you
heard that they're gonna bring greatest
showmen to Broadway okay I've heard that
they're gonna like 100% that they're
being grated show me to Broadway and Ben
saw frozen instead it was unbelievable
I'm sure it is
I mean that's a musical so like that
makes sense [ __ ] Mean Girls it's not
one song I mean girls came out like 20
years it's like yeah and Tina Fey is
involved on and we have to replace it
with something new that's that's just an
indication about how poor our media is
like to every movie that they say is
like the next Mean Girls is horrible
you know what movie I saw that I
actually forgot that I saw because it
was so gettable thoroughbreds oh I
didn't see it oh my god I want to kill
the stepdad yes snichlt like told me
that we should see it that it's like the
next Heather's meets clueless and
everything and I didn't even watch the
trailer cuz I was like well Snitch knows
what's good I saw like a couple people
that I like posted ads for it so I was
like I trust them I like the name I like
the vibe I went to see it we brought
Zach and the whole time during the movie
I was apologizing to him like it was so
bad so bad and I'm so stupid I'm sorry
but it was aesthetically pleasing but
yeah so weird pretty house and you know
who was in it who's in every movie
underrated Lee who that guy who plays
the critic and greatest showman who is
he never sees me in everything but
they're totally bringing they ready to
shove into Broadway they have to they
have to which is exciting for me not
because I'm a big Broadway fanatic but
because then we get more greatest
showmen songs you know I like greatest I
like Broadway when it's like
unbelievable like I'll only see the
creme de la creme I realize now I like
Broadway when it's a spectacular yeah
like it's saying how are they doing that
even though I liked FDR I've been
handsome like I'm I can't see
underplay oh my god I absolutely loved
here Ivan Hanson so much it's the best
movie of all time in every kid in
America should see the best movie oh
sorry the best play I heard they're
making into him they should they should
I think I would like it better maybe his
musical they have all the time the
Curious Incident of the dog in the
middle that I yeah the [ __ ] horrible
guys you need to see the carrots right
here who killed my dog it was my dad I'm
going to London so worse [ __ ] play of
all time to not see yet okay I like
enemy people who don't live in New York
because they don't even have to
entertain the thought of going to see a
play yet they can do normal things no
but then no actually I don't envy them
because when they come to me or anything
that they have to see a fight but you
don't you couldn't spend your whole time
in New York and never go to Times Square
one so yeah be better and you'll have a
better time than if you did okay fourth
story you can find Bethenny Frankel on
these dating apps which include Bumbo
and the league okay Bethenny Frankel
she's just like that if I would ever go
on a dating app mm-hmm like if I ever
needed to I would only go on one where
you like you have to be accepted yeah do
you know what I mean yeah well I have a
lot of experience with dating apps yes
because I was on them for like two years
where did you find the most the most
promised hinge okay
because hinge like works similar to
tinder but you have to have mutual
friends with someone they recalibrated
it so I think now you only get 10
matches a day which is kind of better
because like in excess of matches a
stupid match Factory I love curated
matches also Zach and I probably
wouldn't be together if it wasn't for
hinge because we met at work but we had
also matched on hinge which like told me
that he was like straight and normal
yeah and told the question yes yeah it
does and so oh so many people that I
know that have married or like are
dating someone from a dating app they
also knew them previously they either
met once before and then they matched on
the app or they went out before three
years ago and then match on the app
three years later and now they're dating
two new tinder is too much of like a
hookup no not even that it's too big of
a pond
they'll match it with anyone near you no
I don't want to be matter than anyone
near me I want to be match
someone who I know isn't a serial killer
and might know like my friend from camp
you know so like you have something to
talk about
I never went on bumble but now I hear
that it's maybe it's the best really
yeah that's what people really a while
ago sent me up there was a profile of
someone using my picture I'm bumble
that's so flattering I know it was
honestly truly an honor
yeah and I didn't even report it like I
just yeah she little do you girls things
always work themselves I wonder how I
worked I was on the league lunch which
you have to be accepted to and I found
it to be very douchey but it was also
now like three years ago so so there are
two there are two app so you have to be
accepted to the league and Riya yeah and
riots like if you're cool and like have
Instagram followers no it's not because
I never got accepted into Instagram
followers and every time you're not
allowed to talk about it every day
whatever I'm not on it so [ __ ] it every
time but like that's why I'm ganna prob
rule some of them are on it but they
can't talk about it on bachelor in
paradise amanda was talking about this
when the celebrity tinder which is Riya
but you couldn't say it whatever it's
like I can say it and every time I'm
like hanging out with someone a lot of
my people that I know are on it I always
like ask them to look because I like
just wait and see if I see anyone I know
and I mm-hmm and their words great
pleased to meet famous people yeah
if you ever just wanted like a one-night
stand with a famous person which I
definitely have wanted and I got a
lifetime with one let's leave it at that
anyway so if you're interested in dating
Bethenny Frankel she is on the league
and Bumble but I also thought she's
dating Denis and then a guy in the
Hamptons and Eric Stonestreet remember
and that was a rumor that was an amazing
rumor yeah I wish it was true me too I
can actually see them really like I
think they're friends like it's me too
what is going on with Carol and Bethany
Bethany unfollowed Caroline Instagram
there's such remit there's I was like
talking to enews about it which is like
not the right thing to do right and
she's just had that Bethany's and the
girl she thought she was I disagree I
don't think I like it I like the penny
yeah and I think Bethany's exactly who
you think she's right and if you don't
see the things like if you don't see
fabulous then that's on you that you're
blind yeah you're blind to the truths of
the people that you're friends with
anyways but I think it's good meet you
it's good I just hope that they says in
alienate tensley from the group
I know but Tinsley smarter than that
like this
her career now like she's being smart
about it yes she did see she went to a
situ in Chicago yeah and she cut her
hair yeah it looks good which like she
knew that's what the fans wanted so she
did it I think she probably took a poll
on her Instagram and then like went with
it for sure which is like you got to
give the people what they want we need
fresh hair it's 2018 speaking of giving
the people what they want
Grammy winner pink graces the cover of
people's beautiful issue with her two
kids oh my god I'm so so so absolutely
love pink changing the standard of
beauty she's literally the most gorgeous
talented woman in the world and I feel
like for a while she's regarded as like
an outsider like even myself like I was
like she's an outcast her hair it's too
short
but if Becca Martinez chummy and I think
it's that maybe people with pixie cuts
aren't so bad actually they probably are
the pink is amazing I just love her look
I love the message she sends to her
daughter that was funny that was a good
little rant that was great no there's a
thing there's two you know how I feel
about pixie guts but there's two types
of pixie cuts in the mecha Martinez and
the pink yeah in which one are you here
for pink of course of course and it's
just like if you had told pink ten years
ago when all the Jessica Simpson's
Britney Spears and Paris Hilton's where
people's most beautiful but she was
gonna be people's most beautiful with
her beautiful children like ah it all
comes it's so much more meaningful now
it really is now like what beauty is
it's just not like face value it's just
like who you are who your brand is how
you teach your children you're made of I
just [ __ ] love pink and it's similar
to the Kelly Clarkson it's like finally
like some justice justice some justice
has been served justice has been served
Jews are being paid like it's just it's
it means a lot to me as a consumer
I'm so glad so it's pink and Blake
Shelton are your two most beautiful
people this year I can't really tell -
why he's a good-looking man did you see
him at the ACMs you can't tell me that
he's not a good-looking man no I did I
say that no did I said he's the most
best-looking man okay but next year I'm
telling you it's Jason Momoa it must be
the favorite inside joke from the wrath
is it because I forgot about it like I
needed brain camp and then someone
posted something in the group about
Jason Momoa and someone commented mama
and I was like brought right back to my
writing our top five like inside jokes
okay mama slack for a Perot even though
like it's so oversaturated yes so it was
it was iconic and it's done Spooky's
good morning Millennials and hmm I feel
like there's what can't enchant can't
chant and want can chant and ran and
just the the overall emphasis a ssin of
the boy that affect the way or affect a
bunch it's great um it's better when you
watch them all together I totally agree
I was starting to watch him one by one
and it wasn't gonna I was falling asleep
during each episode so I'm saving them
up okay speaking of saving them up it is
time for dear toasters which if you
don't know is our segment where we give
you all of our professional advice on
your burning life questions and problems
and you guys some of you like really
have such crazy [ __ ] going on so if you
want to submit we take all requests
about weddings relationships by
literally whatever you want at dear
toasters at gmail.com if it's good
enough we will read it online on air
anonymously if you so desire yes also if
we read your thing and you want to
update us please feel free to send us
yeah because we get really invested in
these stories yeah a couple more things
that we forgot that we invented parsed
parsed shadow a better in wha an icon of
our time dirty jeans five days in a row
oh my god I need to come out with a line
of jeans called like dirty jeans five
days was a genius I haven't had a carb
in - yeah but that's also that's in the
spooky yeah it's sub-family
yeah okay I haven't read them and I'm so
excited this is a follow up oh my god my
dream follow up to blackout make out I
just wanted to write in because I wrote
in two dear toasters about my blackout
make out with someone at work and the
whole place didn't speak to me so I just
wanted to follow up and say I found a
new cohort and they've way more friends
now and the scumbag who cheated on his
girlfriend left the company and all the
boys are nice to me and include me in
things just thought I'd brighten and say
the success of Jackie and Claudia's
advice thanks again so much Hey oh my
god I love that please update us if we
ever read your dear toasters on air that
is like not that we really had anything
to do with it but like nobody like me
did and it gave me a bit denim I'm so
glad my pit is resolved like that's one
last pit in my belly I totally agree
stalker much this is a new one since I
was little
this girl let's call her hat I love to
be lethal this girl let's call her
Hannah I literally did everything I did
like two weeks later sports I joined
clubs bought the clothes I wore and gone
missing
me in high school yes we went to
different high schools okay a little
better they're like still yeah so I had
a thing with this guy for five months
last year he lives like an hour for me
and had his hometown so he went away
with school for the summer and then
things because he didn't want to hold me
back
jerk I know so he comes back in a few
months later I see an Instagram that
they're dating stop I never posted an
Instagram with him but he was all over
my stories none of my friends can get
over it do I tell him/her just let them
be and realize how truly crazy she is oh
let them be for sure let them be you
know what like this is like a gift from
God because now you have something to
like laugh about that is crazy I hate
girls like that like I knew girls like
that in high school who like every time
someone did something cool like they
would just piggyback off of it and like
make it their own thing do you mean that
pisses me off so much knows so
unoriginal this girl obviously doesn't
have an ounce of creative spirit to her
so like if this guy is a quality guy
he'll see that and they'll break up on
their own and if he's not a quality guy
they'll stay together and they're meant
for each other and you're about and
you're on to bigger and better things
and you're all tosem block this [ __ ]
from your Instagram stop getting her
ideas wait that's crazy I like I can't
get over
I hate those types of girls like No Oh
like it's so crazy to not have like an
original thought in your body
could you imagine yeah and then all we
do is have originals literally and I'm
very original I'm like a my own but like
sometimes I like to copy other people's
things but like you have to tell them
like like anytime I get something that
like one of my friends has I learned to
hack them like hey me on issues do you
care if I get them yeah and it's still
weird but yeah Elysa being honest about
it flattering it makes it so much better
when you find out on your own that
someone's copying you like through just
like some FBI Facebook stalking yeah
some ti a yeah the truth hurts
investigation Association that's also a
Facebook group if you ever have anything
you want to investigate put it in the
tii and they will figure it out for you
they're sucking so [ __ ] unbelievably
good at their jobs I think honestly the
CIA is gonna start recruiting from yeah
and they should because like formerly
the breath bi now the ti a yeah both
amazing names look amazing organization
we're gonna change it to the bread bi
which is so fun oh that's good too but
the ti a is very official okay
smelly Nelly oh no so I have this friend
let's call her Nellie she is one of my
best friends and I love her so much but
she smells so bad no I smell guys
friends I've tried to tell her multiple
times and tried to fix the problem
myself by literally making sure she was
using body soap or showering but she
still smells
where my clothes and they smell so bad
afterwards I have to make up lies that's
why she can't borrow my clothes because
I have to throw them out after she's
done wearing them okay that needs to
stop immediately
also at this point in our lives friends
don't need to be straight unless you're
like snitches age she still borrows her
friends close and it's like fine yeah
it's a cute for like now she's turned
like six months no for like six more
days because just her English she needs
a girl
I am super grossed out by it and I do
not know what to do anymore because we
are now living together okay you were
just like a glutton over money shooting
yeah you're digging your own grave a
glutton for punishment nice I took their
to go see a doctor but she does not
think it's that serious because she does
not smell it also multiple people think
she smells too it's not just me any
suggestions okay this is like borderline
sad because it's not like no one's
telling her it's like it's obviously a
medical condition and they're like
that's a very real thing where like no
matter how many times you shower how
much odor in how much you literally
scrub your pits like you just smell and
it's like it's like a doctor needs to
look check you out
so definitely recommend her going to the
doctor if you guys are open enough just
be like listen [ __ ] it's like it's not
cool anymore
it sounds like you've done everything
you could do like with the being open
about it and having her put on body wash
like now it's like let dr. Drake romário
handle it and the only thing worse than
like one person smelling bad is it like
two people smell bad and it sounds like
she's rubbing off on you don't want to
be smelly by socially if you if this
friendship means a lot to you but your
team's that it does you guys shouldn't
be living together because the smell has
taken over Natalie and if you only see
her socially you're out like two drinks
you're out to dinner like you can't
really smell her from across the table
and I think your friendship will be
better off so you have to like separate
a little bit if it's really bothering
you this much and also tell her to go to
the doctor not only that just separate
from the smelly thing if you really
treasure your friendship with someone do
not live with them because that's a
surefire way to [ __ ] hate them yeah
I've never have you had that experience
though no but like everyone knows that's
what people think no no everyone knows
yeah I mean there's some people that
live well together I mean I lived with
someone my freshman year but like I
didn't know her and I still hated
herself
wait so maybe it's just you oh for sure
like Sam and Deena lived together
freshman year and every year through
college okay but Dana's not like a human
do you know anything yet it's a day
that's like having a pet she puts up
with a lot but also like Sam's they're
both pretty easy okay yeah I'm not easy
going to miss like a pet yeah it's like
it's like CEO would have mine if
you know me and Thea lived together for
as long as we wanted anybody never form
like any like contention that it would
all be good yeah don't worry okay I hope
we helped you send her to the doctor and
like put yourself send us an update and
in this situation you got to put
yourself first I'm so sick of like
people being smelly in it like I'm so
sick of just like our toasters like
taking the backseat to other people like
you are strong you guys are sunny
doubtful independent women like start
caring about yourselves as much as you
care about other people I'm over caring
about other people like it's me now
I'm the star Three's Company ain't
friends with two other girls and it's
usually just the three of us that hang
out all the time three is such a tough
number oh my god someone always gets
left out but they are starting to not
like each other and don't want to be
around each other it's really hard for
me because now I'm the friend in the
middle and I feel like I have to choose
between them it's also really awkward on
when all three of us are together and
they start being sassy to each other and
fighting any advice you have on how to
deal with this high school drama yes
stay the [ __ ] out of it and like there's
nothing better than being friends with
everyone do you know what I mean yeah on
the Real Housewives that's like not a
thing you can do because they claim like
you need to take sides like in the real
world like being friends with everyone
is your best bet being nice to everyone
it's your best bet not getting involved
is your best bet and if we learned
anything from Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills last night Erica did not get
involved and she was right to do that
and still got in trouble no you gotta
take the Lisa Rinna approach yes Lisa
Rinna is showing us no this is what Lisa
Rinna's doing why she's washing her
hands and it's working and that's what
people should do and I think even if you
have an opinion about it like just go
talk [ __ ] or a confessional like
maybe start a journal or something go to
like church yeah take me to church let's
talk my Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
it was a weird now they didn't feel like
okay this is this is my hypothesis
streets Beverly Beach was supposed to be
the finale that's what I thought
Kyle stormed out and they didn't get the
closure that they usually have so they
did that weird weird makeups oh my god
wait no the view wait I when they're
sitting around on the couch like Kyle's
crying they're watching the show that
they're always ready girls like you know
it's not like wait I [ __ ] love Kyle's
house that's my dream house no but then
when they updated that that's the house
as she got robbed in like you know she's
leading a life of regret because that
wouldn't have happened and if she has
that old house was her safe a lucky
house by the way I told you look I
didn't mean less you didn't get like any
of it back and like all of her bags were
stolen but she has a Birkin that says a
real housewife it's not real how did
that not the Bergen is so not real
really no one would [ __ ] paint no
housewives on a wheel Birkin I was like
she's so many Birkins I know well I'm
not sure that's a present that like Kris
Jenner got hurt when that HAP did came I
could really like my heart sank
I felt I remember reporting on it on the
show and realizing the grat like she
lost over a million dollars worth of
stuff that's [ __ ] crazy and at the
time I was like well you know what she's
not the type that would like harp on
material things but I don't think it's
that I think she's now shook by this new
house right cuz it's a function of the
new house I totally agree and I feel
like she's gonna move next season but
just aesthetically I [ __ ] love her
house that outside of her house is so
gorgeous when they went to her bedroom
and went on the balcony you can oversee
like the pool and then that like gazebo
area oh my god it's so gorgeous
but is it worth losing a million dollars
no PacSun jewelry grandmother's jewelry
no but also I do not like Faye Resnick's
interior design style like at all I
would not hire her she's doing weird
stuff like a lot of it look I'm sure
it's not finished but her bedroom like
looked like what our bedroom yeah it's
like furniture in a room he's not like
an on lifestyle serious or like like
ships like she's renting do you know any
means yeah it's a furniture and a room
yeah it's like okay we got the bed we
got a throw blanket and two two two two
end tables there's no like common like
vision no and there's no like built-ins
you know like it's a house yeah no it
was definitely weird I'm like even the
brand new in the living room like she
did say she said it was her old
furniture that she's not keeping but I
think she just wanted furniture for when
the girls came over yeah but like why
did it have to be like that couldn't
they have all meant like somewhere else
like a movie theater no it was
definitely yeah like Brent at a movie
theater it was definitely very strange I
want to talk about Beverly Beach because
I find that when the housewives have
like their side projects and they throw
these parties they're like so lame and
like sad for the brand yeah that was
like look and we go to events like that
all the time like that was a good event
it was really beautiful really well done
and like I just thought it was like a
well put together party I agree and then
the meat of it the bathing suits were
really cute that's so cute that her
bathing suit was in Sports Illustrated
it's so cute that she named it after all
the ladies except for teddy well that it
never made it so did you see Teddy was
seated in the second row no yes all the
ladies were sitting in the first row
Teddy and her husband were the second
round
I don't know how nobody notice that I
was dying there were so many first row
seats though I know and whether there
were like a couple empty seats I saw
that too so I could have I would have
loved to have been there yeah I'm really
proud of Drita and I agree like half as
a housewife you have to figure out how
to build it for elevate yeah and there
are two weeks
you know like you can go back any Frankl
and like be a mogul this is them or you
can go like gretchen Rossi handbags yeah
and that's not the way you want to go
it's not the way you want to go but you
have to try yeah so no Beverly Beach is
such a cute name it have really good
branding they like obviously hired the
best of the best it's super cute bathing
suits the bathing suits that have that
are not halter but they're tied this way
they've like little boats here are so
cute
and like all the girls are supporting at
least Serena was wearing it like I just
love it no it was it's all very well
done and this is like executed jury lisa
rinna Erika Jayne it's like the trio I
never knew I needed never knew and like
I kind of understood what why Kyle got
upset like basically just like Lisa
Rinna really is up Erica's ass now and
like to reads like they're all like a
trio but her her like analogy if who's
up who's ass was wrong because she said
Lisa Rinna's America's ass Erica is up
to reach ass and to reits up L VPS
that's not true
no it's not true and honestly I wasn't
paying attention during the argument
because I was so [ __ ] over it yeah
they're arguing about really petty stuff
and like that is not a Real Housewives
franchise made like no they're arguing
over like the smallest slights and
things that happened last season like
you cannot bring last season into the
season and yes Tariq started it but Kyle
should really rise above it she should
know better than like TJ that we're not
gonna bring this fight for my season
into this that was really bizarre also
if Teddy brings up Ericka Yeley and her
one more goddamn time I'm gonna kill
myself no no how are people not like
that's the one thing she's hope she
hates Erica so much because of one
little little like little outburst I
have a Napper it's like a little play no
like me the tone in which she's right
three times she brought up in Berlin
twice she brought it up last night and
she would have been her confession oh
this is like just whenever girls get
over it get over it I can't it's making
me so mad and make me even more mad that
Teddy's becoming like a favorite of the
franchise like it's freaking me out
shocking like I'm totally I wanted to
talk about the seating the seating of
how the reunion is gonna be set weeks I
believe how how we're so on not the fan
side like and the fact that I think
juried is more likeable this season
saying I'm loving to read I know she
might not come back less likeable this I
totally agree I don't understand that
what are like is there something wrong
with us or is it I don't know it's
definitely other people this is a
seating chart
so to Andy's left obviously LVP is right
next to him which is so annoying
it's such a prestigious honor to be
seated next to Andy and LVP gets it
every time and she's so unworthy next to
LBP is Dury and next to jury is Erika
Jayne it's so weird they usually split
those couches based on like this high
side but it's not so um it's not so
black and white and I'm it's just weird
that Erika and Lisa Rinna aren't sitting
next to each other but it's also weird
that Erika and I know it's weird that lb
pees on the couch when she has major
people to read and Shady beef with I
agree they even have any overt beef but
like it's totally there you could smell
the beef cooking then to the other side
Kyle's next to Andy which is like
prestigious because she's been there
forever but like I don't know but she's
not well actually Kyle's in the drama
this season so she doesn't yeah but LVP
like is not interesting enough to be in
that seat I completely agree next to
Kyle is Teddy who was probably just
creaming her pants being near Teddy
being there
Kyle next to Teddy is Lisa Rinna yeah
makes no sense and then Camille's coming
in from Yale sits at the end next Lisa
okay this is basically three verse three
Teddy Kyle Lisa Rinna and then LBP
to read Erica Jane this is how I would
have done it I would have done Andy I'm
the Lisa Vanderpump side Vanderpump Kyle
Teddy duh then Erica to reread Rinna or
Rinna to read doesn't matter
no Rinna first she has seniority that's
true but you read is in the thick of it
but Brenna's Maggie's a cannibal really
think of it and she was in the third
seat but when Rinna is the most amazing
person to ever grace her glutes like
it's so crazy because last season I was
like starting to like Rinna and I said
that to you and like you she was crazy
Haines for me she was crazy but I just
had the foresight but what's really
crazy is I don't think Britt do you
think Brandi Glanville's gonna come back
no everyone thought she was because she
treated like such an amazing day with
Andy Cohen but nobody realized that that
Bravo spectacular Linda medley medley
her screen accorded Lisa Rinna have like
major beef do that yeah like granny's
always like making fun of her wig or
something
oh yeah the wig glue yeah but that was
like right when Brandi left and Lisa
Rinna came and they like addressed it on
the reunion I don't know if that's beef
is still real okay they would make it
real if yeah that down for brandy I do
like when they bring back old house size
but brandi was like run dry now she's
like a thirst monster
general for reality TV like I don't know
if I did - yeah I agree I think thirst
monster general is like one of my
favorite phrases
it's unbelievable phrase yeah what is
the original roastmaster general which
is what they call the person who does
the family Central Roast oh is it
yeah I don't know I said the Toastmaster
general oh my god that's amazing but
also cell Toastmaster general yeah no
it's just it's exactly what they are it
perfectly describes someone who is at
their sponsor general and the TMG I I
agree I saw him the group someone put
this is so random someone posted a [ __ ]
marry kill between she Mike Shay Mike
arrival Etta and every second I would
definitely kill Mike Shay I don't need
him or his problems or is music anywhere
near me I would probably mmm I think I
would marry and Rob I don't know like
pros and cons is a cheater and watchin
TV in seven minutes and that's like a
luxury we don't even know that we need
and it totally bit like Eddie has that
like celebrity like lifestyle that like
I might want but it was more money you
think definitely I don't know we'll get
sorry for money cuz Rob Valletta is like
a ambiguous businessman entrepreneur so
he could either have a lot of money or
none of it yeah but they're looking at
houses there's so many people who I
think have like so much money or like
none at all
like who look teddy no I think she
actually is like a million I think she's
like me but she just caught a four
million dollar house oh my god that was
the weirdest updated that like it was a
six billion dollar house but you gotta
refer cuz she's a good negotiator
there's nothing else go yeah that was so
weird and like what do they made one
joke about her being forego I don't even
remember a catch of accountability
debility that was still that seems like
so long ago when they went to Vegas
mm-hmm it wasn't long I know so they
didn't show a preview for the reunion
next week did you see one like I said
yes I saw a commercial during usually
this yeah I'm real has eyes and i was i
love reunions me too they're better than
me by the third reunion i don't love
them anymore but then they do three
anymore for everyone for everyone but
they did it for atlanta and Lana always
get to stay because there's not enough
time in the day and II always on
Instagram stories like the recording of
their Atlanta housewives
they're literally there for like 15
hours that's insane it's crazy so that's
our episode let's do a toast today yes
we let's serve up justice first
did we serve up justice for time we
served of justice for pink and Kelly
Clarkson yeah and I think that should
just be the general mantra of today's
show just like you know look past the
vein and the shallowness of it all and
like look for real talent and that's
Kelly Clarkson and pink I agree
Cheers so just this weird I know and a
toast to hmm who's worthy of a toast
like we could do a toast to [ __ ] I was
think I mean we could always give them
to tiffany thornton but that should just
be like a back but back fault like if we
just oh yeah but what are the stories we
spoke about say I'm like having amnesia
no I know um we spoke about pink
feel-good Taylor Swift uh-huh we spoke
oh you know what to the bush legacy
chart i toast to Barbara Bush to Barbara
Bush may her memory serve as what are
they saying whatever nice they remember
e-service something positive yes Bush
are you okay I don't want to end the
show like this is bad let's start with
no but the thing is the toast is for
Barbara yeah okay no so be like and now
a toast mmm who's me oh I know Barbara
Bush and the entire Bush legacy may her
memory be a blessing and may her family
and the mourners be at peace char's
thank you all so much for tuning in
today if you missed our big update we
are now on patreon as well so if you
want five extra episodes a month feel
free to go over the traditional premium
content that's not podcast episodes
that's videos that's photos that's
whatever we feel like sharing with you
that we don't have time to share on the
show or that's a little too personal
feel free to head over to the morning
shows patreon it's $8 a month but this
show will remain unchanged free and
wonderful you know all that we are also
a little PSA
why don't we lose the ability to talk
like five minutes ago
like I'm not okay I lost like ten
minutes ago but you hadn't so I don't
know if anyone you know I'm not feeling
joy I think we should just start all
over okay
everybody see what I was gonna say it's
like a reminder we're out we're on
vacation next week we're on vacation
next video not leave you empty-handed we
are doing eight podcast episodes with
sisters with boyfriends with husbands
it's gonna be really good so make sure
you subscribe to the morning toast and
the podcast app we're also on Facebook
we're on YouTube we're on Instagram at
the morning show so make sure you follow
us there tickets for my Caroline show
are still available there's like I think
maybe 50 left so you might as well you
might as well just do it now
hi I'm Claudia ash a girl with no job
I'm Jackie I show you Jackie O problems
thank you for watching we'll see
[Music]